I'm here at the Autodesk Gallery with David Larsson.
David was the lead developer on a product called Beast for game developers.
Many of the lighting demos you'll see in this unit were developed by David.
So, David, as a start, what's your background?
&gt;&gt; I got a Commodore 128 as a Christmas gift. My brother and I got it together.
And we started programming and exploring this basic environment, which is,
which is basically the operating system, but also a programming language, which
you end up in, when you boot up one of those computers. And, I was kind of
reading over the shoulder, and asked my brother to, you know, type in listings
from computer magazines and instruction manuals and we, you know, started
making programs. And that's kind of how we got started, programming together.
And when I was growing older, I got involved in something called the demo
scene, which is basically, just teenagers trying to outdo each other with
graphic effects and visual effects on, computers. And that was a really good
boot camp for, for learning about graphics programming and and programming in
general and also like, you know, running projects. It was a really effective
way of, of learning all those tools that you need in order to, to become a, a
good programmer. So a few years, I had a time, when I was in college I also
temporarily worked for a game studio. And then, some time, when I was in my
last year of college, a friend, actually another guy I knew from the demo
scene, he asked me, if you, I wanted to come work for, the company they had,
and that company is, was, Illuminate Labs. which is a, at that time we were
developing a renderer that was kind of a general purpose rendering, renderer.
And at some point we realized we have to narrow, like focus group, and what we
did was target it towards game developers, and you know, things got much
bigger, and eventually we ended up being acquired by Autodesk. That's where
I've been working for the last two and a half years.